hey guys I could really use some help
with the video mind a buddy of mine
named mark Drager friend of the channel
been on multiple times on the channel
over the years I've known him for years
he used to have this series on his
youtube channel called mark in the car
where he would give his thoughts his two
cents his opinions on the state of his
business the state of entrepreneurship
the state of what was happening in the
world and I always loved that I thought
it was practical I thought it was
tangible
I loved getting his two cents on things
and he stopped he stopped doing it and
it upset me and I met him recently I
said mark you gotta bring back mark in a
car so he made this video he put it up
on his channel the first return of mark
in a car and what I would love love love
for you to do is please go to the video
support him he doesn't know I'm making
this video he's gonna freak out when
when I when I when it comes out and he
finds out he's gonna be happy and a
little bit embarrassed which is great I
love that go to the video check it out
and just encourage him leave a comment
give it a thumbs up show some love how
many of you have been in a place with
your business where you didn't believe
in yourself where you felt like you
might be wasting people's time where you
felt like your opinion didn't matter and
nobody cared and somebody came along and
I just gave you a little bit of belief
in yourself and that was a little umph
that you needed to just keep going this
is your chance to do that for an amazing
human being who cares a ton who has an
insane amount of value to bring to the
world please check the description go to
the video leave a comment drop some
believe love on this fine human being
give some encouragement it would mean I
know I mean a lot to mark I mean a lot
to me personally as well thank you guys
- love it you need to believe and
whatever your one word is
lowers volume yeah the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details